[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with journalist and
broadcaster Jenny kleeman and a chief
political correspondent at the telegraph
Camilla Turner they'll be with us from
now writer until just before midnight so
let's see what's on the front of some of
those newspapers for you now or the
families of victims of the Manchester
Arena attack are pictured on the front
of the Guardian as it looks at the
inquiry into mi5's devastating failings
leading up to the bombing
the front of the Daily Express looks at
former prime minister Boris Johnson's
response to the New brexit Deal the
headline rishi's deal will not take back
control
is this proof the party gate probe was a
labor plot reads the front of the Daily
Mail as it leads on the appointment of
Sue gray as secure starman's chief of
staff
the front of the times also leads on
this story with the headline PM urged to
block new job for parties Inquisitor
the Metro leads with the great betrayal
in reaction to the Hancock allegations
quoting the ex-health minister has been
betrayed
we're going to get heavy with the police
reads the front of the Daily Telegraph
as they quote Matt Hancock's WhatsApp
messages discussing a Crackdown on the
public during the covid pandemic
the front of the financial times looks
at fears over the London Stock Market
after the world's largest building
materials group listed in New York
rather than the city
clowns plotted to kill all our kitties
read to the front of the Daily Star as
it looks at claims that the government
looked at getting rid of Britain's cats
in the early days of covid
not heard that before and a reminder
that by scanning the QR code you'll see
on screen during the program you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us and we are
joined tonight by journalist and
broadcaster Jenny cleeman and chief
political correspondent at the telegraph
Camilla Turner welcome to you both
um before we get to the uh interesting
story on the front of the star let's um
kick off with the Telegraph and Matt
Hancock's WhatsApp messages more
Revelations Jenny
yes this is the latest set of
Revelations and in fact I think the cat
message is on the front of the star may
come from from this uh set of text
whatsapps that have been leaked uh by
Isabel oakshot to the telegraph of
course Matt Hancock's what what's that
message is this is the third day of
Revelations and uh it doesn't disappoint
in terms of being troublemaking because
for people who are still incredibly
angry about Downing Street parties and I
do think a lot of the countries is angry
about Downing Street parties still no
matter what your political persuasion uh
the revelations in today's well
tomorrow's Daily Telegraph are really
going to stick in the core because they
are about uh how ministers uh gave
officers orders to strictly enforce
covered rules within days of Downing
Street parties and it shows how Matt
Hancock was particularly instrumental
um in trying to get those rules enforced
Matt Hancock as health secretary at the
time wouldn't have had much to do with
the police but apparently according to
these messages he was rallying to be
present during meetings where pretty
Patel and Boris Johnson will be talking
about uh getting the police to really
make sure people weren't breaking
lockdown rules those same lockdown rules
that we know were being broken in
Downing Street this is the third day of
this these Revelations are still
explosive uh and they look so bad for
Matt Hancock he will say of course that
we only get to see uh one side his side
we don't get to see things in context of
course he's going to look particularly
bad he's quoted here saying I think
we're going to have to get heavy with
the police at one point he talks about
trying to pursue Nigel farage for
drinking a pint uh in supposed
contravention of of quarantine rules
he'd been flying back from somewhere I
vaguely remember this he tweeted himself
having a point when he should have been
quarantining and of course Nigel farage
and Richard Tice uh who is uh you know
they were the big leaders of this
anti-lockdown movement Richard Tice of
course is Isabel oat Short's partner
Isabel oakshot is the person who's
leaked these messages so if you're still
following it does look like there's a
bit of a vendetta again to Matt Hancock
but you know there is an arguable public
interest in these messages a lot of
people will be extremely angry at the
hypocrisy of ministers pushing for the
police to be so heavy-handed as
heavy-handed as possible at a time when
they weren't prepared to obey the rules
themselves yes and Camilla what what
have you made of the increasing uh
Revelations uh day by day
um yes so we're on the third day now of
these um Telegraph stories
um the paper's been looking at them
thematically so we had Care Homes fast
um and then schools and children next
and now we're on to police
um and the sort of enforcement of these
covid
um measures which of course was one of
the most controversial parts of
um what happened to
um the British Society
um during the the pandemic months is
these very sort of heavy-handed tactics
used by police
um to crack down on people
um having picnics having barbecues
um meeting perhaps more than one friend
at a time all these sorts of things that
seem completely alien to our society
normally and even at the time drew some
comparisons with a sort of orwellian
State
um and and here what we can see and from
these messages is really
um government ministers senior officials
and Matt Hancock taking a sort of
delight in
um these heavy-handed tactics and
wanting the police to to talking about
giving the police marching orders
wanting to get heavy with the police so
really trying to urge
um ever stricter law enforcement and
this is particularly interesting I think
given that the government throughout
this period and in general stress the
operational Independence of the police
but here we can see actually senior
police officers being hauled into
Downing Street and told they need to be
even stricter with the public than they
are already uh just uh very quickly just
another line on this story
um Jenny and the the article suggesting
that this perhaps cast out on the the
covert inquiry the much delayed covert
inquiry do you agree with that
well I mean I think the the issue with
all of this and and the the
justification for releasing these
messages is that the inquiry uh is going
to take too long it's in the public
interest to put these messages out there
um I don't know I think if it was in the
public interest to put these messages
out there maybe Isabel oakshot should
have done that before she worked on on
the book with Matt Hancock and took the
fee uh to to work on that book
um I don't know whether or not this is
going to jeopardize the inquiry because
the inquiry is going to have everyone's
messages we'd hope and and not just Matt
Hancock's
um but it certainly doesn't help the
inquiry necessarily because there is a
opinions being formed without all the
evidence being at hand okay let's move
to the times and the appointment of Sue
gray as a case-stama's um Chief of Staff
not an appointment that is looked on
favorably by the conservatives Camilla
um yes that's right so this time story
talks about
um the Prime Minister being urged to
block this new job for Sue gray
um Sue gray of course a senior a veteran
civil servant Who Rose to fame um when
she led the party gate inquiry until
that time she was probably little known
outside of White Horse circles
um and now she's accepted this new job
um she's quit the Civil Service and
she's going to be working as kirst
armors Chief of Staff now this has
infuriated allies of Boris Johnson who
say they shouldn't be allowed to happen
first of all second of all doesn't this
just show that the party gate inquiry
was one big stitch up it was an attempt
to sort of paint Boris Johnson as a
villain um and now we can see Sue Gray's
True Colors
um and and they're saying the prime
minister is being urged to block this
new job
um for Sue gray so whether that will
happen or not um remains slightly
unclear whether it's fair to say that um
Sue gray is
um you know somehow didn't carry out the
party gate inquiry properly just because
she's now leaving the Civil Service to
work for labor I'm sure she would also
argue that that's a slightly unfair
criticism but nevertheless this is
something that has really
um riled up the allies of Boris Johnson
uh Jenny the the claim is that she could
use privileged information to to benefit
labor
um and that's the the suggestion
obviously civil servants are meant to be
neutral
I think it's a fair point to say that
she meant details of allegations against
uh other conservative uh MPS
um which could be exploited by labor the
question is how much of a grace period
is she going to get between jobs how
much gardening leave I think labor
assumes she's going to have some uh
gardening leave
um she wouldn't would just step straight
into the job but you know you have to
remember she was absolutely bigged up uh
by the conservatives when she was
appointed to investigate partygate as a
completely unimpeachable impartial
um source so the idea that I mean that
you have the kind of Usual Suspects of
Jacob Reese MOG and Nadine Doris saying
that this means that the party get
inquiry was was a stitch up and that is
part of some kind of internal labor plot
I think that's the front of the daily
mail
um I think that's taking things to
extremes
um but um it is fair to say that moving
forward it is slightly awkward because
she will be privy to a lot of
information that might potentially be
useful uh to the labor party and I think
that there's some grumblings within the
Civil Service about how this might
um cast civil servants
um in in a more dubious light that civil
servants will will fear that they won't
be seen as impartial in future they will
be seen as maybe people who have eyes on
a future political role
do you agree with that uh Camilla that
this this has raised an issue for civil
servants and their their impartial role
um I think it's an interesting broader
point but um you know some people are
having that debate already this idea
that
um the civil servants have sort of given
up on the Tory government there's leaks
coming out left right and Center all
these complaints going in about
ministers and this idea that actually
they're just kind of sitting around now
and waiting for a labor government to
come in
um whether I think you can extrapolate
that view just from this one move by one
person or be at a high profile
individual um but just by Sue gray
leaving the Civil Service to work for
labor it seems like a bit of a stretch
to them
um say oh everyone in the Civil Service
um wants to work for labor um but I
think that that is a view that's been
going around Whitehall this idea that
it's kind of knives out for the Tories
because
um some people within the Civil Service
feel like frankly this is the dying days
of a conservative government and they're
now just waiting around for for labor to
come in and Jenny can the Prime Minister
ultimately block this move I know you
can hold up the appointment and she can
be on prolonged gardeningly but but
could he ultimately block the
appointment do we know
well the financial time says so it says
that Rishi sunaka is considering
blocking her from from taking up the
role
um it is interesting it's a very it's
not just any old role I mean kirstan was
Chief of Staff their job is is to
prepare labor for government and I think
you know her appointment
would be seen as an endorsement for
labor that they're seen as a as a
serious Contender for government they
have serious people working behind the
scenes
um so I'm sure Rishi Suna would want to
to step in if he possibly could I don't
know the ins and outs of of uh
appointment processes uh when it comes
to this kind of role or when it comes to
uh civil servants Moving on but the Ft
certainly says it's something that he's
looking at interesting Jenny and Camilla
stay with us both we're going to take a
break coming up
families Fury devastating MI5 failings
in Manchester bombing that's on the
front of the Guardian do stay with us
for more
[Music]
foreign
the Press preview still with me
journalist and broadcaster Jenny kleeman
and the telegraph's chief political
correspondent Camilla Turner welcome
back to both of you let us have a look
at the guardian and this story
concentrating on the uh report on the
Manchester Arena attack and the the
failings of MI5 were pictured there the
uh well it's a very emotional day for
the families uh one family telling us
that they'll never forgive those that
they hold responsible Camilla
um yes that's right this is now the
final report of the um public inquiry
into the Manchester Arena attacks and um
some very Stark findings from from the
inquiry saying that there were
significant missed opportunities to stop
this attack
um that um had Intelligence been acted
on sooner by the security services then
um there may have been a chance to avoid
such a a terrible disaster which of
course was the deadliest plot we've had
on UK soil since the 2005 attacks in
London
um the MI5 director General has taken
the very rare step of issuing a public
apology
um saying that he has deep regret
um that the security service didn't have
enough intelligence to to stop the
attack so clearly the the marking of
this the end of this inquiry will
hopefully bring some closure to the
families although the frustration for
them is that a lot of the hearings to do
with the security material were had
behind closed doors so whilst they
weren't privy to all of that information
there's at least that final conclusion
of the inquiry and the verdict that um
the role of the security services
um clearly played an important role here
and um and one that leaves some some
massive learnings for the future
yeah so you do Wonder Jenny whether they
they can ever get closure there's a
quote here from Andrew russos whose
eight-year-old daughter Safi Rose russos
was killed in the blast he blamed MI5
for a cataclysmic failure uh he said the
spy agency was not fit to keep us safe
and therefore not fit for purpose I mean
it doesn't sound as if the the ending of
the reports the inquiry is going to
bring any closure whatsoever for the
families
no it's really painful for them because
obviously so much of the evidence in
this third tranche of the report was
behind closed doors for for security
reasons and it isn't so much that uh
they didn't have the right Intelligence
on Salman abedi it is that it wasn't
communicated it wasn't passed on quickly
enough that's what we kind of know but
we don't know the specific details of it
and you know when you lose someone in
such tragic circumstances I'm sure you
are desperate for any scrap of
information that can help you understand
uh what happened how we can learn from
it how we can make sure that this this
death wasn't totally in vain because
there are wider things that you can
learn and so the fact that this was done
behind closed doors is going to be uh
painful for those families the one thing
that we do know from these three parts
of this investigation is uh that it
shouldn't this this terrorist atrocity
shouldn't have happened he slipped
through the net fewer people may have
died if the Emergency Services to
differently if the police acted
differently and and if the security
service has acted differently so it's a
it's a very painful very difficult set
of conclusions for families at the end
of a very long inquiry and Camilla you
mentioned the MI5 directors apology how
significant do you think that really is
um I think that is quite a significant
step here because of course we don't
often hear much from MI5 they sort of
operate um covertly behind closed doors
it's not an agency that has a huge
amount of interaction with the public
but I do think given the seriousness of
um the the conclusions of this report
and just how much
um you know some of that culpability is
placed onto MI5 and how they could have
done more they could have acted faster
they had intelligence but they didn't
use it speedily enough to intervene to
perhaps stop this attack from going
ahead I do think that the the pressure
on MI5 to say something rather than just
remaining silent
um probably was just too big in this
occasion
um meaning that they were almost forced
into this quite public apology
to the express Jenny and uh former prime
minister Boris Johnson shouting from the
rooftops that he will not be supporting
Rishi sunx brexit deal another yet
another intervention from the former
prime minister
yet another intervention you know this
is a man who at one point couldn't
decide whether or not to campaign for
leave or remain has now set himself up
as the Perpetual Arbiter of what brexit
is and he says brexit is not uh Rishi
sunak's deal in Northern Ireland uh you
know I think Boris Johnson
um is not as relevant as he was he's
less relevant than he's ever been for
years and he is just an irritant now I
think he knows this himself he said
today at the speech at Queen Elizabeth
Hall uh where all the other conservative
MPS were on this big away day that he
didn't attend
um he said he was conscious of the
momentum and it was not going his way he
knows it isn't with him but he's not
going to vote for this deal
um so you can't help but think what is
he doing then just trying to be annoying
just biding his time to see whether or
not
um he can come back if there's an
opportunity there is going to be some
sort of rebellion whenever a vote on
this deal uh comes but how big it will
be isn't another question that your ERG
seems to be split and uh you know Boris
Johnson doesn't hold the sway that he
used to Jacob Reese Morgan said he's
going to support Rishi sunak
um so you know if Jason Jacob Reese
Morgan is saying it um I don't think
people are necessarily listening to
Boris Johnson the way they used to but
Camilla would you actually ever expect
him to support Rishi sunax brexit deal
because in doing that then he's then
admitting that that his his uh efforts
were were very very poor
yes I think that's right and one way you
can read this whole um you know what's
played out over the past few weeks with
this brexit deal that Rishi is secured
with the EU is that really you can see
it as a fight between Boris and Rishi
and we had just before the big deal was
revealed by Rishi sunak we had an
intervention from Boris Johnson
um saying it would be a great mistake to
abandon
um the Northern Ireland protocol bill
which of course is something Boris
Johnson pioneered during his time as
prime minister we then have Rishi sunak
saying I've got this great deal and
there's no need for the Northern Ireland
protocol Bill anymore I'm going to
completely rip that up and get rid of it
um so you know there goes Boris
Johnson's Legacy we've now had Boris
intervening once again saying well I'm
not going to vote for this deal
um I still think we need to to keep the
bill so we've got this tussle going on
between Russia sunak and Boris Johnson
the current and the former prime
minister clearly people who aren't each
other's biggest fans
um and I think what will be interesting
about this latest Boris intervention is
just how much swear it will hold on
other conservative party MPS we've had
um plenty of MPS I think over a hundred
including some of the most Ardent
brexiteers already saying they support
the deal but we are waiting to hear from
others so it remains to be seen when the
forest's influences what it used to be
Jenny just very quickly at the Daily
Star front page tell us why all of our
cats had a very near miss with death
I I wish I could uh this clearly comes
from some of these uh leaked whatsapps
uh but uh it just goes to show that in
the early days of the pandemic nobody
knew what was going on there was a there
was an idea that uh perhaps we may need
to Cull all the cats in case they were
vectors of covid fortunately that idea
didn't uh didn't catch on and the cats
have lived another day thank you very
much very concise uh we still don't know
the answer to that question thank you
both uh Jenny and Camilla
let's take a look at the weather